Speaker 1: Let's go to Jack from
Atlanta. Jack from Atlanta, welcome
to the program. What can I do for you today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can you hear me? Yeah.
Awesome. Well, thank you so much. I had a
question. I know you've repeatedly said that
you still do not believe that Trump will ever
see one day in prison. I'm still wondering,
given all the evidence and the severity of this
arraignment he had yesterday and the charges being
made against him, why do you still believe that?
Speaker 1: So I've actually updated my view
on this, Jack, and I'm glad to have the
opportunity to do it again. Prior to this week,
prior to this recent indictment, I believed
that there was no chance Trump would even
see a day inside of any kind of cell. I now
believe that it is unlikely but possible.
So I have sort of upgraded or downgraded,
depending on your perspective. My my view
on that on the basis of this latest indictment.
Speaker 2: Well, one could only hope. And one
last quick question. I thought of it after the
last speaker gave this question. Do you find
it at all startling that a lot of corporations
have actually forgone posting their logo as a
Rainbow logo for Pride Month? Because it used
to be the case where almost everyone would do
that. But now I guess maybe they've realized
that, hey, now it's not financially viable
to do that anymore. Does that at all scare you?
Speaker 1: You know, I don't know that to be true.
And what I mean is I'm not saying you're lying. I
just pay so little attention to what corporations
are doing as far as the logos. I know that on the
very powerful David Pakman show Discord, we did do
a modified server logo that includes the rainbow
stripe for the month, as we always do. I it's I'm
not. Are you aware like what specific companies
used to do it but aren't doing it anymore.
Speaker 2: I know I've seen like a lot of
just random companies like Cisco or Starbucks
or post their Twitter profile picture as their
logo, But the rainbow ified version and I feel
like I just have seen very few of those this
year. And I mean, I give I just saw this isn't
exactly the logo thing, but I saw on the news
today that Starbucks is actually rolling back
some of its Pride decorations at over half
of its stores. So I was just I don't know,
it's a little bit startling how now
a lot of corporations I mean, yeah,
rainbow capitalism is a lot of times empty virtue
signaling. But yes, I don't know. It's a little
bit worrying that now that's being it's being
perceived as, hey, this isn't the right thing
to do given the current political climate.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, because I don't
have the actual empirical information in
front of me. Let me comment in this way.
We all know that the vast majority of these
decisions are simply marketing and PR decisions to
increase the bottom line. It wouldn't be shocking
to me that if it became disadvantageous to do the
pride thing, that companies would immediately
stop doing it. I would find it disappointing
and sad because that would be a horrible thing,
that it's no longer that it would be unprofitable
in some way to just say, hey, like we're we're on
board with with just treating everybody the right
way. It wouldn't be a huge shock because
these are at the end of the day, they've
always been financially oriented decisions.
Speaker 2: Exactly. Thanks for taking my call,
David. Have a good one.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
There goes Jack from Atlanta. Very
powerful declarations there. And we
are glad to. Glad to hear them. Why don't
we go to Molly from Utah? Molly from Utah.
Welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hi. So last time I got cut off, I don't
know what happened, but there things I was going
to talk about is that the DSA has over 185 seats,
both state, local and including national get.
Speaker 1: Molly, just. Just. Just the total
peace and love of we I if we can get I know that
there was a very long lead up going on and DSA
is not something that I'm super engaged with and
know very little about it so. So I just if we can
get to the question part relatively soon or even
first, I can tell you whether I can even weigh in.
I don't want to waste your time, you know.
Speaker 2: Yeah,
but it's basically that they've been doing
local actions. They've been doing local
activities and have been gaining ground.
So what do you think about those efforts
when it comes down to electoral reform?
Speaker 1: I know nothing about what the
DSA is doing or where they've been gaining
ground. And as a non socialist myself,
it's not something I'm advocating for.
Speaker 2: It's over the entire
country. They've been going on since 2016.
Speaker 1: And you mean in in elected office?
Speaker 2: Yeah. Elected offices, both state
and local and national. That just like five
members of Congress that are DSA members.
Speaker 1: Listen, what I can tell you is
when movements succeed at getting candidates
elected, it's good for them. But beyond that,
it's really tough for me to say, say too much
more. It's not a group I'm a member of or
what I'm, you know, supporting at this time.
Speaker 2: All right. Just I would recommend
looking into. They seem to be advancing pretty
well. And that's just like the the opium of
like change is possible. They are able to do it.
Speaker 1: All right. Molly from Utah, thank you
very much for the call. I appreciate that. Let's
take a very quick break. We're going to go right
back to Discord and hear from more people.
So don't go anywhere. We're just taking a
very short break. Let's go back to the phones.
They're not really phones at this point. It's
all digital. We take calls via discord. You can
find the Discord server at David Packman, dot com
slash discord. Let's go to Roy from Somalia. Roy
from Somalia. Welcome to the program. What is on
your mind today? Roy from Somalia. Please accept
my invitation and then we'll be able to talk.
Speaker 2: My bad, sir. I was wondering
about the situation in Uganda with the
the gay rights bill and how terrible it is.
And I was wondering your thoughts on that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I have. This time around, I mean,
this is the same bill that they've been following
for a very, very long time, if I recall correctly.
Collective. I mean, ten years ago I interviewed
this crazy pastor who was supporting the bill.
They were talking about the same bill, right?
Speaker 2: Yeah, that's right.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Listen, it's so
disgusting. And in some sense it's shocking that
in 2023, this sort of aggression against people
simply for being gay is still going on. I am
so far removed from the specific comings and
goings of Ugandan politics that it's really
hard for me to say, like what needs to happen
or what should happen. I mean, there are people
who follow that specifically much more closely.
But it is extremely disheartening that this is
even still that there's any effort being wasted
on scapegoating people and targeting people
for their identity. It's just disheartening
and disgusting at the at the end of the day.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I agree. And only one member of
their legislature actually voted against it. The
others from the opposition stayed home. You know,
there have been U.S. sanctions and I
think those should be ramped up. But
it really is just unfortunate.
Speaker 1: Unfortunate is the
understatement of the century, Roy, for
sure. Do you do you live in Somalia?
Speaker 2: Oh, no, That was
a lie. I'm from South Jersey.
Speaker 1: Oh, okay. All right. Well,
very, very unusual. On that note,
we're going to let you go try to tell the
truth. Okay, guys, try to tell the truth.